[Music]
the billy eilish and rosalia collab
we've all been waiting for
is finally here i'm so excited i'm
actually so excited okay so it's been
almost two years since they were first
seen in the studio together
and on thursday they dropped their new
song titled
lovas ah olvidar which translates in
english to
you will forget and guys it's
freaking fire
[Music]
bonus fact the track is also featured in
the upcoming second special episode of
the hbo show euphoria
billy and rosalia first announced their
song on tuesday
sharing a super short clip of them alone
in a dark open room
then on thursday they shared that their
song was out
billy writing quote i love this song so
much
now here it is for you to enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
of course the two singers first teased
their collab on twitter back in march
2019
sharing this pic in the studio feels
amazing it feels great
i feel very really grateful the spanish
singer captioned the tweet in part
quote can't wait to finish our song
later that year
rosalia teased the collab to et at the
2019
latin grammys so what do you want fans
to know about that collab
i mean we've been in the studio yeah
you're right and we we enjoyed
making music together and i hope
i hope that we find more time to finish
what we started
and that's it so it's not done yet we
started something
and let's see but you're having fun with
it and experimenting absolutely yes in
the studio i always try to
write as free as possible and with her
it was amazing chemistry and i can't
wait i can wait
[Music]
can you let it go
can you let it go